how many people here have a tick tock  raise your hand like consume tick tock  wow less than I thought actually  um so for the people in here use  hashtags of some of the words in your  world and take a look there's like a lot  more how-to videos from this sector  being done there's some people making  paper  by getting clients from Tick Tock behind  the scenes stuff is crazy it's very real  it's the same old game I don't  understand how so few hands went up more  people just keep making the same mistake  the same people that didn't get on that  didn't raise their hands to get on Tick  Tock also didn't get on Facebook because  they thought it was a kid thing  and everybody here knows Facebook in 15  years went from college kids to grandmas  and so these things grow like a  restaurant like a nightclub they mature  differently and I'm just shocked that  people's audacity to think their  personal opinion is a good business  strategy